this one essentially often used to say
hide your arm behind your back on doing
this
so it comes out
this arm needs to take the shortest
journey
not
big see if
he said if you just stand there like
this your hands already out there and
it might get hit
you know if you leave it there so
stick it on your your hip
grab the hand the coat of gosh hand
shortest journey
[Music]
shortest journey hands across legs are
cost
okay
as you get better
it goes like that these
scissors of feeling go like that
make sure you this happens
because you'll find that sometimes
you'll be throwing them and the gel will
be on their side not your side so you do
have to
add this little piece at the end
if you oh
i made it look where my feet are i can't
cross them over now
so
you'd have to do
another technique something else i know
what you do
okay so
[Music]
one
make it so you can cross cross
okay and he must fall exactly
he's like the letter t i'm the stalk
he's the top of the t
if this happens you know this is for you
seniors really to check your own are you
using sorry
how do you talk
um
it's to show you if you're using upper
body strength or not
if you do it like this
and you throw him
and he's there
it means you used upper body strength
physical
if he ends up exactly on a tee every
time
[Music]
t
to you
then you've got it correct